hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today we're going to go back in time and
talk about an important influence on the
English language the influence of the
Vikings and their language Old Norse
it's almost universally accepted that
English is a West Germanic language
along with Frisian Dutch and German and
that modern English descended from
anglo-saxon also known as Old English
the language spoken by Germanic tribes
that migrated to Great Britain in the
fifth century as I mentioned in my video
is English really a Germanic language
English vocabulary was highly influenced
by French after the Norman invasion in
the 11th century in the subsequent
control of England by the anglo-norman
but there's one more piece of the puzzle
English was also highly influenced by
Old Norse after Viking invasions and
Danish and Norwegian settlements in the
8th 9th and 10th centuries a large
section of England was under Danish
Viking control from the Year 878 to 954
at its largest around half of England
under a regime known as the Danelaw both
English and Scandinavians lived in the
area of the Danelaw and through
extensive interaction and intermarriage
the culture of the area became heavily
Scandinavian influenced and of course
there was contact between their
languages Old English and Old Norse
after the English reasserted control
over this area the culture of the area
remained heavily Scandinavian influenced
and Danish attacks against England
continued there was even a period of 26
years from 1016 to 1042 when the Danes
controlled all of England this period of
Viking influence continued until the
Norman invasions which began in 1066 the
exact linguistic situation of that time
period is not known but we know that Old
English and Old Norse were closely
related before the Viking invasions
began in the year 793 the anglo-saxon
tribes had arrived from across the sea
between the 5th and 7th centuries they
spoke in Viana collect Anglo frisian and
old Saxon dialects and existed in close
proximity with speakers of proto Norse
before the anglo-saxon migration these
dialects were likely all mutually
intelligible so with only a couple of
hundred years between the anglo-saxon
migration and the Viking invasions their
languages were likely still mutually
intelligible at least to a limited
extent at the very least there were many
similar cognate words despite the
Germanic connection between Old English
and Old Norse we can see that the
differences between Old English and
Middle English are striking that English
underwent a change and simplification in
grammar and that many Old Norse words
were adopted into English vocabulary as
we know Norman French had a big impact
on Middle English making up around 30%
of English vocabulary by the end of the
Middle English period but if we leave
French aside and just look at the
Germanic vocabulary of English it looks
like this words with cognates in both
Old English and Old Norse make up 50% of
the words words found only in Old
English make up 36% and words found only
in Old Norse make up 14% you might be
thinking only 14% that's not so many Old
Norse words but also notice that 50% of
the words had cognates in both languages
this could mean that as Middle English
developed the English and Scandinavians
had the tendency to choose words that
were common to both languages as this
would obviously make communication
easier
and while 14% may seem like a fairly low
number a lot of those words are very
basic and common words that's important
because when a language borrows
vocabulary from another one it usually
borrows words that are more advanced or
more literary or words for concepts that
couldn't be expressed in the language
before borrowing basic words usually
requires an intense prolonged period of
contact between the two languages here
are some examples of basic words that
entered English from Old Norse the
third-person plural pronouns came from
Old Norse these are the ancestors of
they them and their words related to
animals reindeer from Old Norse reindeer
Gosling from Old Norse gas linger which
was borrowed into Middle English as
gesslin the word for egg from Old Norse
egg
wing from Old Norse Venga which became
Middle English wingait or wenge nature
and landscape bark from Old Norse but
occurred route from Old Norse wrote this
was borrowed into late old english wrote
sky from old norse ski and the original
meaning was cloud negative words anger
from old norse anger die from old norse
deya
which entered Old English as dion which
became Middle English day in ill from
Old Norse allure which entered Middle
English as ill a rotten from Old Norse
roten which entered middle english as
roten ugly from old norse Booga or ugly
guru which entered middle english as
Oobleck a words related to the body leg
from old norse leg ger skin from old
norse skin words for common objects beg
from old norse buggy ball from old norse
bowler knife from old norse conifer
which entered late old english as
kenneth verbs the plural present tense
of the verb to be
in other words are came from Old Norse
Edda call from Old Norse Cola which
entered Middle English as Colin hit from
Old Norse HIDTA which entered middle
english as hittin take from Old Norse
taka which entered late ole English as
token which became Middle English talkin
these are just some examples to give you
an idea of the types of basic everyday
words which were borrowed from Old Norse
around the thousand words of Old Norse
became part of standard English but that
number is significantly higher if we
include some of the northern dialects of
English like the Yorkshire dialect
grammar in the transition from Old
English to Middle English English went
from being a synthetic language with
lots of inflection to a highly analytic
language which relies on word order and
prepositions instead of inflection nouns
lost their case inflections nouns used
to occur in four different forms
nominative genitive dative and
accusative and occasionally in a fifth
case the instrumental case for example
in old
English there was this phrase meaning
the heavy stone with the word for stone
being a masculine strong a stem noun say
heaviest an tha's heavy and stannous
femme heavy an Stan a zone' heavy on
Stan and in the plural form meaning the
heavy stones the heavy on Stannis
Dada heavy Dostana the heavy om stannum
the heavy on Stannis in Middle English
these different forms were mostly lost
for the singular there was just the
heavy ston and for the genitive form in
other words the possessive there was the
heavy Stannis in the plural there was
just the heavy Stannis with the ending
of the nominative and accusative cases
becoming the plural s in the noun
distinct cases were lost except for the
genitive and the different forms of the
definite article were all reduced to say
which was a variant of say from Old
English and unstressed it was pronounced
thoug in all case in number distinctions
were lost in the adjectives also in Old
English the definite article and
adjectives were declined differently in
the feminine and neuter genders but all
of those gender distinctions were lost
there were various other plural endings
for different genders and classes of
nouns in Old English but the plural form
from this particular class of nouns
became generalized to most nouns another
plural ending was also common en which
still lingers on in a few words like
oxen brethren and children though this
one children actually combines two
plural forms childer plus en this is a
form of simplification in which a
particular irregular form becomes
regularized another change many verb
inflections were also lost Old English
verbs mainly fit into two groups strong
verbs and weak verbs strong verbs formed
the past tense through a change in a
vowel in the verb stem and weak verbs
formed the past tense by adding a suffix
after the verb stem o day and oDesk
in the singular and Odin in the plural
in middle english the past tense endings
in week class to verbs developed into
regular past tense endings which today
are just IDI
many strong verbs disappeared and new
verbs adopted the weak past tense forms
this is another example of how English
became simplified and regularized in
Middle English the use of auxiliary
verbs to supplement verb tenses also
began for example in Old English there
was no specific future tense the future
was expressed with the present tense
conjugation but in middle english
shillin meaning Chou and willin meaning
will began to be used as future markers
hey shall okay meaning he will look or
he shall look and seal then hey use will
a meaning he will shield us in other
words he will protect us this was a sign
of English becoming a more analytic
language as it lost its inflections the
word order of English also became more
fixed as English lost its inflections in
Old English say heaviest on would be
clearly nominative normally the subject
of a sentence so you could move that
phrase around and it would still be
clear that it was the subject but in
Middle English the heavy ston could be
nominative dative or accusative so to
show it's the subject it would normally
be first followed by a verb and then an
object or a compliment if there was one
so how did the contact between Old
English and Old Norse caused or
influenced these changes a lot of this
comes down to speculation based on small
bits of information that we have despite
the violence of the initial Viking
invasions in the areas under
Scandinavian rule it seems clear that
the anglo-saxons were not driven out or
kept separate from the Scandinavians
they lived in close proximity with each
other and at least in certain areas and
at certain times they were highly
integrated with this context in mind
there are several theories about the
contact between Old English and Old
North the traditionally held consensus
is that Middle English descended
directly from Old English without
interruption and that outside influence
from Old Norse did not change the West
Germanic core of the language in this
traditional view Middle English
developed with an Old Norse substrate
this means that as Scandinavians adopted
English changes entered the language
through imperfect learning on their part
or borrowing from Old Norse on the part
of English speakers there's a minority
view that middle English was a Creole
in other words a new language that arose
from contact between Old English and Old
Norse with influences from both Creoles
usually arise when communities of people
who share no common language come in
close contact with each other and they
come up with a new language out of
necessity
this pidgin language is created by
adults then it becomes a native language
of the next generation one typical
feature of Creoles is that the
vocabulary is mostly derived from the
higher prestige language while its
grammar is a drastically simplified
version of the lower prestige languages
grammar if English is a Creole that
means that it cannot be classified as
either West Germanic or North Germanic
but one problem with this theory is that
true Creoles are usually more
grammatically simplified and regularized
than middle English Creoles usually
begin as pidgin languages created by
speakers of mutually unintelligible
languages
so rather than combining both languages
they create a simple new language from
scratch and they normally don't have
gender and case in pronouns singular
plural distinction verb inflections for
person or tense passive forms and so on
but middle english retained all of those
things maybe that's because Old English
and Old Norse were so similar to begin
with that they didn't need to create an
entirely new language to communicate
even if some creolization did take place
if they already shared a lot of common
vocabulary but the grammatical
inflections caused confusion
maybe they spoke in a dumbed-down or a
simplified sort of way with fewer
grammatical inflections in order to
communicate that doesn't really fulfill
the criteria of a pidgin but maybe we
could call it a semi pidgin or something
like that and if their children grew up
in that household hearing their parents
speak a semi pidgin and they adopted
that as their native language then maybe
we could call that native language a
semi creole there is also a
controversial new theory that English is
actually a North Germanic language that
means that Scandinavians didn't learn
Old English but rather the English
learned Old Norse so middle English is
actually based on Old Norse at its core
with lots of influence from Old English
so according to this theory English
doesn't descend directly from Old
English but rather from Old Norse along
with Swedish Norwegian Danish ice
and Faroese the basis of this theory is
that the syntax of middle English and
modern English reflects Old Norse in
numerous ways here are some examples in
English the verbs come before the object
I can play the piano
this is similar to the North Germanic
word order in Norwegian guy comes below
piano in the West Germanic languages
Dutch in German the second verb comes at
the end after the object it come pianos
balaam it can play via spielen Old
English was similar to Dutch in German
in this regard another difference
preposition stranding this means that
prepositions can come at the end of
clauses without the noun that usually
follows them so in English we have that
issue was talked about in Norwegian than
[ __ ] les musket ohm preposition
stranding is actually very rare among
the languages of the world split
infinitives despite whatever your high
school English teacher may have taught
you split infinitives are very common
and normal in English modern North
Germanic languages are the same in
English you can say I promise to not do
that again with - not to do in Norwegian
you can say yellow little it cured the N
in both languages the negation adverb is
placed in the middle of the infinitive
splitting it not only the negation
adverb but other types of adverbs can go
there as well split infinitives did not
occur in Old English and they do not
occur in Dutch or German they did
however occur occasionally in Old Norse
those are a few of 14 different
syntactic elements that occur in both
English and North Germanic languages but
not in Old English how do we know that
these features weren't simply borrowed
from Old Norse into Old English well
this theory is based on the
understanding that when one language
borrows from another it usually doesn't
borrow structures it borrows mainly
vocabulary but I don't think that's
quite true language structures are
sometimes borrowed when there is
extensive long term contact between the
languages and when there is extensive
bilingualism amongst speakers of the
borrowing language Old Norse was not
simply the language of the elite it was
spoken by people living side by side
with the speakers of Old English so
there was likely intense contact as well
as a lot of bilingualism
therefore Old English certainly could
have borrowed structures from Old Norse
and not just vocabulary so I'm not
convinced that English is based on Old
Norse in my opinion and I freely admit
that I'm speculating here I think that
the traditional consensus still stands
but there may also have been some degree
of language mixing because of childhood
bilingualism it's quite clear that Old
Norse made a bigger impact further north
in the Danish controlled areas so up
there there was likely more language
mixing but when Middle English was
standardized the East Midlands dialect
was chosen as the basis of the standard
it was sort of the midway point between
the northern more Scandinavian
influenced dialects and the southern
more Anglo dialects this definitely
limited the amount of Norse influence so
that modern English today is more West
Germanic than North Germanic even if
some of those northern dialects tend a
little more towards North Germanic the
question of the day to speakers of North
Germanic languages and people who have
studied them what kinds of similarities
have you noticed between English and
your language and to speakers of other
languages has your language been
influenced by others as a result of
language contact
let's leave modern English borrowings
aside and think more about historical
contact between different language
communities be sure to follow Lange
focus on Facebook Twitter and Instagram
and once again thank you to all of my
patrons on patreon especially these
patrons right here on the screen
they are my top tier patreon supporters
so very many special thanks to them and
everyone thank you for watching and have
a nice stay
[Music]
[Music]
you